franck est plombier depuis quinze ans et
il a rencontré tellement de femmes qu'il
en est devenu philosophe
bonjour puis tout au long de la
rencontre les femmes aussi charmant
comme ça ça permet de donner un petit
peu de fiabilité ou travail ça vous
plaît elle à ce travail normal pas mal
parce que seul on frappe à une porte
comme ça on jour on sait pas qui est
derrière pour moi ben plombier dans ma
tête c'était pas du tout comme ça il
était grand et est blond il ya les
grands yeux bleus
il ya de belles mains était superbe et
je sais pas ce qui m'a pris tout d'un
coup je me suis sentie bidart toute
molle j'ai eu envie de ce garçon j'ai eu
envie de faire l'amour avec lui contre
les belles femmes sur une moyenne de ils
ont un mois
5 si ce sont vraiment des affaires quoi
je l' ai pris par la main et je vais
carrément emmené dans ma chambre est
alors la nuit' les faits certes toujours
gentil alors gelé en reste et je
l'embrassé et puis je me suis mise
bombay fallait agir je me suis mis
talent des familles est alors moi j'ai
craqué l'émotion devant lui et puis je
me dis bon il faut y aller et l'amener à
passer la journée ensemble
j'aime à paraître tu peux communauté si
vous aimez mais je ne considère pas
quand même envoyé bête mais il est vrai
qu'ils madame ça se passe j'entretiens
des relations
et puis ces relations france boralex
étant le seul dans qu'est ce qu'ils font
mais qui s'ennuient qui seul est bas les
sensations sont plus fortes
je n'ai jamais revu par contre j'avais
agi parce bon j'y pense quelques fois
j'en garde un souvenir assez ému parce
que c'était pour moi une très très belle
aventure